on comptait hier plus de 30 mille cas
positifs un chiffre que nous n'avions
plus atteint depuis novembre dernier
après plusieurs mois marqué par un
plateau se situant entre 15000 et 20000
cas par jour
le virus gagne de nouveau du terrain
depuis une semaine le virus progresse en
france comme presque partout en europe
je pense à l'allemagne à la belgique aux
pays-bas ou à l'italie même dans les
pays qui ont confiné comme chez nous il
se passe quelque chose depuis quelques
jours et dans tous ces pays
l'explication la plus évidente tient à
l'apparition de cette nouvelle forme de
virus que l'on appelle les souches
variantes dont nous mesurons la
progression jour après jour la plus
répandue dans notre pays vous le savez
est de loin celle dite du variant
anglais qui concerne désormais peu à peu
près la moitié des personnes atteintes
de l'aco vide en france ce variant nous
savons depuis la fin janvier qu'il se
diffuse à bas bruit y est qu'il est
susceptible de produire à un moment
donné une nouvelle flambée épidémique
parce qu'il est plus contagieux avec le
président de la république nous avons
souhaité le mois dernier nous donner
tous les moyens d'éviter un nouveau
confinement que nous avions envisagé fin
janvier sur la base de projections qui
nous prédisaient une dégradation rapide
et brutale
la situation cette décision s'est avérée
la bonne nous a permis de gagner du
temps or ce temps est précieux car
chaque jour nous avons un peu plus de
personnes vaccinées
et pendant ce temps notre activité
économique ne s'est pas effondré le
commerce ont pu rester ouverts nos
enfants ont pu aller à l'école dans les
zones bien entendu qu'ils n'étaient pas
en vacances il faut imaginer qu autour
de nous je pense au royaume uni ou à
l'allemagne
les enfants n'ont pas mis les pieds à
l'école depuis plus de deux mois grâce
aux efforts de tous
nous avons pendant plusieurs semaines
réussi à stabiliser l'épidémie c'est une
réussite collective que je veux saluer
j'entends également certains appeler un
confinement dur et immédiat dans
l'espoir de nous débarrasser une bonne
fois pour toute du virus quatre semaines
et puis on est débarrassé
malheureusement notamment en raison de
la propagation des variants c'est loin
d'être aussi simple
voyez d'ailleurs que les confinements
très dur auquel ont procédé certains de
nos voisins ne leur ont pas permis
d'atteindre l'objectif zéro corrie un
confinement peut-être nécessaire mais il
n'est jamais anodin il signifie des
fermetures de commerces la fermeture des
écoles des limitations drastiques des
déplacements j'observe d'ailleurs que
beaucoup de ceux qui appellent au
confinement général se disent très
souvent quand on les interroge plus
précisément opposé à chacune de ses
modalités
il faudrait confiné mais sans fermer les
commerces sans fermer les écoles ça
rétablir l'attestation de déplacement
le confinement est ainsi un levier
auquel nous devons recourir quand on ne
peut pas faire autrement il faut le
faire à bon escient au bon moment et
dans la bonne mesure il faut tout faire
pour le retarder pour laisser à la
vaccination
le temps de produire des effets notre
objectif reste toujours le même tenir
traverser cette crise qui se prolonge en
sauvant le maximum de vies en protégeant
nos hôpitaux mais aussi autant que nous
le pourrons en préservant nos modes de
vie notre économie l'éducation de nos
enfants
la recherche de ce juste équilibre de ce
difficile équilibre a toujours été et
restera la colonne vertébrale de notre
action c'est pourquoi notre choix de ne
pas confinée à une contrepartie être
extrêmement réactif aux premiers signes
de reprise épidémique
c'est ce que nous avons fait ces
derniers jours un engageant des actions
ciblées sur certains territoires marqués
par une augmentation particulièrement
forte de l'épidémie en moselle
face à l'émergence du variant sud
africains qui représentent 60 %
des cas positifs la vaccination des
professionnels de santé a été accélérée
et la stratégie tester alerté protégé a
été démultipliée à mayotte où la
situation a conduit à la mise en place
d'un confinement qui sera prolongé pour
au moins 15 jours de plus à la réunion
où comme à mayotte nous déploierons les
moyens humains et matériels nécessaires
pour venir en soutien des structures de
soins enfin dans l'air urbaine de nice
et dans l'agglomération de dunkerque où
la circulation des niveaux trois à
quatre fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale a été constaté et où un
confinement sera mis en place le
week-end à compter de ce samedi
nous devions agir et nous l'avons fait
avec le soutien des élus de ces
territoires dont je veux saluer ici
l'esprit de responsabilité
le confinement le week-end est une
mesure lourde
ce d'autant qu'elle se conjugue avec le
couvre-feu maintenu à 18 heures c'est
une mesure intermédiaire dont nous
espérons qu'elle permettra d'infléchir
la tendance observée
c'est une mesure ciblée sur certains
territoires où l'épidémie s'emballe ce
qui nous semble la bonne méthode pour
pouvoir agir vite et fort
là où c'est nécessaire sans impact et
des territoires où l'épidémie recule il
y en a où circulent moins fortement
et sur cette base sur ce diagnostic il
apparaît aujourd'hui que la situation
épidémiologique spital hier dans
d'autres agglomérations ou département
suscite une vigilance maximale car ces
territoires cumul des indicateurs
défavorables
un niveau d'incidence élevée autour ou
supérieur à 250 cas pour 100000
habitants une part de variance
supérieure à 50% une pression
hospitalière proche du seuil critique et
enfin une circulation virale qui
commence à s'accélérer
sérieusement ces départements au moment
où je parle devant vous sont au nombre
de 20 il s'affiche sur la carte et
concerne toute l'île de france
une grande partie des hauts de france et
de provence alpes côte d'azur mais aussi
les départements du rhône et de la drôme
de la moselle et de la meurthe et
moselle et en faire deux heures et loire
nous plaçons donc ces départements
surveillance renforcée j'ai demandé aux
préfets des départements concernés
d'engager des concertations avec les
élus en vue d'inviter sans attendre
tous les habitants à la plus grande
vigilance et d'envisager dans tout ou
partie de ce territoire des mesures de
freinage proches de celles mises en
place à nice et dunkerque
nous ferons un point au terme de ces
concertations la semaine prochaine et
nous déciderons alors si et seulement si
la situation continue à se dégrader
nous prendrons des mesures renforcées
qui entreront en vigueur à compter du
week-end du 6 mars
mes chers concitoyens je mesure ce que
peut être votre lassitude et peut-être
même votre découragement alors que nous
sommes engagés dans cette bataille
depuis bientôt douze mois le virus
évolue et se transforme et certains
d'entre vous peuvent se demander si nous
verrons bientôt le bout de ce jour sans
fin j'en ai l'absolue conviction et
cette conviction se fonde sur des
premiers signes tangibles des premiers
motifs d'espoir nous permettant
d'envisager dans les prochains mois un
retour à une vie normale
c'est la campagne de vaccination c'est
notre stratégie de dépistage que nous
améliorons sans cesse c'est aussi
l'arrivée prochaine de nouveaux
traitements
la campagne de vaccination se poursuit
et s'amplifie à la fin de ce mois de
février tout proche plus de 4 millions
de vaccins auront été administré à près
de 3 millions de personnes avec là
encore le concours des élus locaux et
des professionnels de sang
c'est que je veux remercier nous
vaccinons beaucoup et surtout je veux
insister auprès de vous nous vaccinons
les bonnes personnes c'est à dire celles
qui peuvent développer les formes les
plus graves de la maladie présenter des
séquelles lourdes ou parfois en mourir
vous le savez il s'agit des personnes
les plus âgées et ou présentant des
pathologies ap les comorbidités qui les
rendent particulièrement vulnérables à
la maladie et que l'on retrouve dans les
services hospitaliers
c'est pour cette raison que nous devons
poursuivre la vaccination des personnes
de plus de 75 ans et amplifier la
vaccination des personnes atteintes de
comorbidité car les statistiques nous
montrent qu'elles présentent de plus
forte probabilité d'être hospitalisés ou
d'être gravement atteinte
et cette stratégie se déploie
si certains pays qui nous entourent ont
à ce jour davantage vacciner que nous la
france est en tête pour la vaccination
des personnes les plus exposées aux
formes graves de l'aco vide comme
l'illustrent les graphiques à l'écran
l'âge moyen des personnes vaccinées est
en france de 72 ans contre 65 ans en
allemagne et 55 ans en italie près de 80
% des résidents des ehpad
là où le taux de mortalité a été le plus
élevé sont désormais vacciner plus du
quart des personnes de plus de 75 ans a
été vaccinée d'ores et déjà nous
constatons que le virus circule moins
chez les personnes âgées qu'en
population générale
depuis deux semaines l'incidence baisse
chez les plus de 80 ans quand elle
augmente dans toutes les tranches d'âge
inférieure l'âge moyen des personnes
admises en réanimation diminue cela
montre que les effets de la campagne
vaccinale commence à se faire sentir sur
nos concitoyens les plus
âgé donc les plus fragiles qui sont
désormais mieux protégés
aujourd'hui marque une étape nouvelle
avec l'entrée en scène des médecins
généralistes et des pharmaciens dans un
premier temps les généralistes vont
pouvoir vacciner les patients âgés de 50
à 64 ans atteint de comorbidité soit un
objectif de 2 4 millions de personnes
avec le ministre des solidarités de la
santé j'ai donné ce matin symboliquement
le coup d'envoi de cette campagne
et d'ici fin mars les deux tiers des
personnes de plus de 75 ans seront
vaccinés et nous ouvrirons début avril
la vaccination aux plus de 65 ans pour
autant nous dépendons de la fabrication
et de la livraison des doses commandées
par l'union européenne et il faudra nous
armer de patience mais je sais que vous
mesurez ce chantier titanesque et sans
précédent que représente pour
l'industrie mondiale
le fait de produire des centaines de
millions de doses en un temps record
produire des vaccins eux-mêmes découvert
en un temps record il n'en reste pas
moins qu'à la mi-mai la totalité des
personnes de plus de 50 ans se seront
vus proposer une première injection
olivier et veyran et le professeur alain
fischer reviendrons sur cette stratégie
vaccinale dans un instant nous pouvons
aussi compter sur notre système de
dépistage la fameuse stratégie tester
alerté protégés que nous ne cessons de
renforcer l'accès au test est facilitée
notamment dans les établissements
d'enseignement avec le déploiement des
tests salivaires qui doivent permettre
rapidement de tester trois cent mille en
forme par semaine c'est à dire près de
six fois plus qu'aujourd'hui et donc de
mieux les protéger pour l'ensemble du
pays les délais de dépistage et de rendu
des résultats continue à se réduire
le tracking surveillance des cas contact
est désormais quasi immédiat après
l'identification d'un cas positifs et le
dispositif d'accompagnement à domicile
des personnes isolées se déploient
partout sur le territoire national
et là encore je le souligne pour la mise
en oeuvre de ce dispositif totalement
gratuit un grand merci aux
professionnels de santé notamment dans
les laboratoires les caisses d'assurance
maladie les ars les collectivités
locales et les associations
troisième motif d'espoir l'arrivée
prochaine de nouveaux traitements qui
pourraient permettre d'éviter
l'apparition de formes graves de la
maladie
il s'agit notamment des anticorps
monoclonaux qui vend vous être présenté
par le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé le soliste
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs où l'avait dit monsieur
premier ministre après deux semaines de
baisse de la circulation du virus dans
notre pays nous enregistrons à nouveau
une hausse assez sensible quotidienne il
ya plus de vingt-cinq mille cas par
exemple diagnostiqué au cours des 24
dernières heures contre 22 mille cas
jeudi dernier
nous pouvons dire que hélas en une
semaine nous avons effacé les deux
semaines de baisse qui avaient précédé
cela n'est pas une surprise cela n'est
pas étonnant et vous l'avez dit cela se
constate partout autour de nous du fait
de la pression qui est créée par la
diffusion de ces fameux variant du coc
vie de 10,9 dont on sait qu'ils sont
plus contagieux qui devait résumer la
situation je dirais que grâce aux
mesures de gestion que nous avons mises
en place et notamment le couvre-feu le
télétravail
grâce au respect des gestes-barrières
par les français nous arrivons à faire
reculer encore le colis de 19
tel que nous le connaissions jusqu'à
présent dans notre pays mais du fait de
sa plus grande contagiosité intrinsèque
c'est à dire que le virus par lui-même
est plus contagieux quand il est un
variant et bien nous n'arrivons pas à
faire reculer cette diffusion du variant
qui lui holt et qui elle augmente
d'environ 40% par semaine et qui a pris
une telle place aujourd'hui dans la
circulation virale dans notre pays qu'il
en dit l'induit une hausse du nombre de
nouvelles contaminations
ce que vous voyez sur ce graphe donc on
continue de faire reculer le kobe de
10,9 tel que nous le connaissions on
limite la contagiosité du variant mais
pas suffisamment pour éviter
l'augmentation des cas je le redis c'est
un phénomène qui concerne tous les pays
qui sont dans lesquelles au sein
desquels vont circuler ces variants sur
la diapositive suivante vous allez voir
qu'en réalité il y a un impact
hospitalier liés à cette augmentation de
la diffusion du virus avec des
hospitalisations qui avait baissé alors
on ne voit pas encore la hausse des
hospitalisations mais on sait depuis un
an que lorsque le nombre de cas augmente
et bien le nombre d'hospitalisations va
finir par augmenter quelques jours après
de la même manière la tension dans les
réanimations reste forte dans notre pays
vous voyez on est pas réellement sorti
la deuxième vague en terme de charge
hospitalière et de charges de
réanimation et les médecins des équipes
soignantes nous dit
combien c'est difficile au quotidien de
faire face à un afflux de malades
vous l'avez dit c'est une donnée tout à
fait nouvelle et je pense fondamental
pour la suite c'est que l'âge moyen des
patients admis à l'hôpital l'âge moyen
des patients qui font des formes graves
aux urgences ou en réanimation cet âge
moyen diminue de 6 7 ans en moyenne
c'est à dire que les patients en
réanimation qui avait plutôt 63 ans
désormais semble se diriger vers une
moyenne d'âge vers 55 ans ça veut pas
dire que le virus est plus grave chez
les jeunes ça veut dire qu'il ya moins
de personnes très âgées qui sont malades
du fait de la vaccination et du fait que
ces personnes sont protégés ce qui veut
dire que on peut espérer ce serait la
suite logique et nous le serons bientôt
que pour cent malades données et bien il
lui est moins de formes graves
proportionnellement qu'auparavant ce
serait évidemment une très bonne
nouvelle je lisais la diffusion du
variant elle concerne désormais tout le
territoire national avec une
hétérogénéité qu'on voyait sur la glace
hurle la carte de france on peut la
remettre
qui qui fait que les territoires qui
sont plus ou moins touchés que d'autres
mais globalement aujourd'hui plus d'un
cas sur deux de nouveau de nouvelles
contaminations dans notre pays est liée
à du variant anglais et environ 5 à 6 %
des contaminations sont liées à du
variant dix brésiliens ou encore
sud-africains
voilà pour ces informations vous dire
également que l'impact hospitalier dans
certaines régions il est plus fort que
dans d'autres c'est notamment le cas en
région paca ou en othe france et que
nous sommes obligés d'organiser au
quotidien ce qu'on appelle des
évacuations sanitaires pour transférer
des malades en état grave
souvent en coma avec incubation
ventilation artificielle d'un hôpital à
un autre d'une même région
voir ça pourrait reprendre d'une région
à une autre région tant la charge
hospitalière peut être importantes par
endroits et cela nécessite cela justifie
pleinement des mesures nouvelles qui ont
pu être prises qui ont pu être prises
que ce soit à nice ou à dunkerque et qui
pourrait donc être prises dans 20
départements supplémentaires dans les
prochains jours comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre il faudrait
que cette constatation se fasse et que
si nous constatons encore une hausse de
la pression épidémique des décisions
soient prises
un point effectivement sur la
vaccination pour vous informer de l'état
des lieux aujourd'hui des publics qui
peuvent bénéficier de cette vaccination
si vous avez je le rappelle 75 ans ou
plus que vous soyez en établi si vous
êtes en établissement pour personnes
âgées en ehpad normalement vous avez été
vaccinées puisqu'on a couvert 80 % des
personnes âgées en établissement
collectif et donc c'était la cible que
nous avions fixé les 20% restants sont
en général des personnes qui sont contre
indiqués pour la vaccination ou qui ont
émis à plusieurs reprises un refus 80%
c'est une très belle couverture de la
population la plus fragile
si vous êtes âgé de 75 ans et plus et
que vous vivez chez vous et bien vous
pouvez prendre rendez vous sur internet
sur le site sante.gouv.fr ou par le
numéro vert national ou en appelant
directement le centre le plus proche de
chez vous il y en a mille deux cents sur
toute la france pour prendre rendez vous
pour vous faire vacciner avec ce qu'on
appelle les vaccins à arn messager c'est
à dire les vaccins pfizer et modern à la
vaccination de ce public de 75 ans et
plus se poursuit
elle va se poursuivre en mars et nous
devrions nous espérons avoir terminé la
vaccination de toutes les personnes
âgées volontaires d'ici à la fin du mois
de mars permettant donc ensuite d'ouvrir
la vaccination aux 65 ans et plus si
vous êtes plus jeunes voire beaucoup
plus jeunes mais que vous figurer sur
une liste de personnes qui sont
atteintes de maladie particulièrement
grave qui a été élaborée d'ailleurs par
le professeur fisher et qui fait que
vous êtes très fragile aux risques du
virus vous pouvez aussi vous faire
vacciner en centre de vaccination avec
une prescription médicale avec les
vaccins pfizer et moderna si vous êtes
âgé de 50 à 65 ans vous l'avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre et que vous
êtes atteint de comorbidité c'est à dire
des maladies qui vous expose à des
risques de formes graves de qu'ovide
vous pouvez contacter votre médecin
s'ils ne vous a pas contacté lui-même et
vous pouvez vous faire vacciner en
cabinet médical de ville directement
aujourd'hui 35 mille français ont été
vaccinés par du vaccin astrazeneca
c'est entre trois et quatre fois plus
que le rythme habituel de vaccination du
fait de l'ouverture pour ce public
âgés de 50 à 64 ans atteint de
comorbidité le professeur fisher vous en
parlera mais c'est vrai qu'il y à une
partie de la population qui s'interroge
légitimement et qui se demandent quand
son tour va enfin revenir je parle des
personnes qui ont entre 65 et 75 ans
qu'elle ait des maladies ou qu'elle n'en
ait pas aujourd'hui de fait les vaccins
arn messagers kaiser et moderna sont
réservés aux personnes les plus âgées
parce que elles sont prioritaires et les
vaccins un type astrazeneca ne sont pas
autorisés aux personnes âgées de 65 ans
et plus il y à une étude très
intéressante dans le professeur fisher
vous parlera qui permet d'espérer qu'en
réalité le vaccin astrazeneca serait
beaucoup plus efficace que ce qu'on
redoutait et notamment chez les
personnes âgées
ça pourrait évidemment changé la donne
sinon sachez que si vous avez entre 65
et 75 ans vous accéderez la vaccination
par les vaccins arn messager quoiqu'il
arrive d'ici le mois d'avril
si vous êtes résident dans un
établissement hébergements collectifs
avec une avec un handicap et que vous
avez un accueil spécialisé vous pouvez
être également vaccinés en astra zeneca
voilà pour l'organisation actuelle à
date de la vaccination
un dernier mot effectivement c'est une
très bonne nouvelle en tout cas nous
l'espérons c'est sur le plan des
traitements et des traitements très
innovant il en existe au moins deux
sortes
d'abord il ya ce qu'on appelle un
traitement par interféron l'interféron
est un vieux médicament qu'on utilise
dans différentes maladies et qui vient
compenser des déficits d'interféron chez
certaines personnes
l'interféron finalement c'est une
manière pour l'organisme de réagir face
à des infections et si vous êtes en
carence et en interférant on peut vous
administré ce traitement et ça pourrait
limiter le risque de formes graves
ce sont des équipes françaises notamment
l'équipe du professeur casanova mais
également les études qu'on appelle
l'étude cobras edge qui est menée par
l'équipe du professeur malvy qui a lieu
dans toute la france et qui permet dans
le cas d'une recherche clinique dans un
cadre protocole ise bien précis à des
personnes qui sont à risque de
développer des formes graves de recevoir
ce traitement
nous serons dans quelques semaines si ce
traitement est efficace le deuxième la
deuxième nouveauté thérapeutique c'est
ce qu'on appelle des anticorps
monoclonaux
là aussi des traitements très innovante
il en existe plusieurs sortes je vous
fais grâce de l'explication du
fonctionnement de ces médicaments qui
est très complexe mais sachez que l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament a accordé ce qu'on appelle
une autorisation temporaire
d'utilisation des anticorps monoclonaux
pour li
éviter les risques de survenue de formes
graves chez des personnes dont l'état de
santé les expose à des risques
particulièrement élevé de formes graves
là il ne s'agit pas à proprement parler
d'études cliniques on est déjà dans une
pratique thérapeutique évidemment
encadré quelques 83 centres hospitaliers
ont déjà reçu des milliers de ce
traitement qui pourront commencer à être
administré avec prudence initialement
dans un cadre hospitalier pour des
patients âgés de 80 ans et plus et qui
ont des troubles de l'immunité
mais la france et c'est le premier pays
européen à l'avoir fait à commander des
dizaines de milliers de doses
d'anticorps monoclonaux d'une génération
supérieur qui arriveront en france d'ici
à la mi mars et qui nous permettront je
l'espère sincèrement d'amplifier ces
protocoles thérapeutiques et d'élargir
la cible des publics qui pourraient
bénéficier de ce traitement
tout cela est fondé sur des études
cliniques qui ont été faites notamment
aux états unis et qui montrent qu'il
pourrait y avoir une réduction majeure
des risques de forme grave j'ajoute que
les premiers premier traitement que nous
avons commandé et ça ne fait pas de mal
ont été produits en alsace ce qui montre
que la production des médicaments en
france se porte bien
de ce point de ce point de vue là voilà
ce sont donc des pistes thérapeutiques
intéressant désespoir nouveaux qui
permettront nous n'en doutons pas de
renforcer notre arsenal de moyens pour
lutter contre la diffusion de ces virus
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre j'ai
souhaité que des explications
complémentaires vous soit donnée sur
notre stratégie vaccinale et je demande
donc au professeur alain fischer qui
vous le savez le président du conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
de bien vouloir s'exprimer à présent
merci ce professeur merci merci monsieur
le premier ministre
merci monsieur le ministre donc
effectivement aujourd'hui une nouvelle
phase de la vaccination s'est ouverte
avec comme cela vient de vous être
indiqué la possibilité pour les médecins
généralistes aussi les médecins du
travail de vacciner avec
le produit astrazeneca donc est une
nouvelle étape qui va permettre
d'amplifier de diversifier la
vaccination donc ce après tout à
l'occasion de cette nouvelle phase c'est
peut être intéressant de faire un point
sur les connaissances sur les vaccins
dont nous disposons car il se trouve que
dans les deux trois derniers jours une
série d'informations tout à fait
positives viennent conforter l'intérêt
d'utiliser ces mais ces vaccins de les
utiliser bien sûr la façon plus optimale
possible au bénéfice du plus grand
nombre
en ce qui concerne le vaccin riser comme
vous le savez le l'état d'israël a
commencé à vacciner massivement sa
population et de façon assez rapide
aujourd'hui même est sorti une étude est
publié une étude dans le new england
journal of medicine qui fait état des
résultats de la vaccination chez les 500
mille premières personnes qui ont été
ainsi vacciner dans ce pays comparé à
500 600 milles environ personnes qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés et c'est cette
étude montre que l'efficacité du vaccin
est largement aussi bonne confirme très
largement même un tout petit peu au
dessus les données qui avaient été
publiées lors des études de phase iii
avec ge est entré dans le détail des
chiffres mais une protection contre la
maladie contre les formes sévères de
maladie contre l'hospitalisation contre
les décès même c'est la première fois
qu'il y ait donné qui concerne les décès
qui dépasse 90% des personnes donc c'est
une excellente nouvelle
alors un tout petit élément prudents et
que par définition ce sont des résultats
qui sont fondés sur des études de court
terme les chiffres quelques quelques
chiffres que j'indique son se situe à
après l'administration de la seconde
dose qui doit être administré qui est
indispensable pour obtenir ces bons
résultats
trois à quatre semaines après la
première et sept jours plus tard donc
fait évidemment une étude à court terme
il ne peut pas en être autrement il
faudra suivre au cours du temps si ce
qui se passe une seconde de nouvelles
que l'on peut tirer de cette étude ce
travail assez remarquable et très
rapidement publiés qu'est ce qui est une
très bonne chose c'est le fait que les
personnes âgées les personnes âgées de
plus de 65 ans les personnes âgées de
plus de 75 ans les personnes âgées de 80
ans bénéficient également de cette
protection comme des personnes plus
jeunes
et il était fait allusion tout à l'heure
aux remarquables succès je pense de la
vaccination dans les maisons de retraite
en france donc très vite on devrait
pouvoir
déjà on en a entendu les premiers
éléments les premiers signaux pensé voir
cela se traduire la même façon en france
avec des taux de protection des 95 % de
personnes déjà vaccinées qui permettra
d'observer la réduction
d'hospitalisations et de décès donc
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle pour
toutes les personnes seniors qui ont été
vaccinés ou qui vont être vaccinés
donc voilà un premier élément ensuite je
souhaitais passer un tout petit moment
pour évoquer la situation du vaccin
eiser dieu qu'est-ce que c'était moi du
vaccin astrazeneca je vous rappelle que
c'est d'un vaccin qui est fondée sur le
principe des adénovirus qui sont des
petits virus inoffensif rendu incapable
par ailleurs de se répliquer et qui ont
été modifiés pour qu'ils permettent
d'induire une réponse immunitaire contre
ce qu'on appelle la spaque une protéine
essentielle du virus pour enclencher
entre autres la réponse immunitaire des
premières études cliniques de publier de
la firme
astrazeneca qui a développé ce vaccin
montré un certain taux d'efficacité
initialement 62% mais si on réexamine
leurs études avec de nouvelles
publications
et lorsque ce vaccin est administré
façon optimale
il permet d'obtenir après la première
dose un taux de protection de leurs 2
76% et qui monte à 82%
si on respecte un délai assez long dans
ce qui est le cas de ce vaccin
un délai de douze semaines entre la
première et la seconde injection
donc des résultats plutôt plutôt
encourageant néanmoins il se trouve pour
des raisons je trouve profondément
injuste je vais expliquer tout de suite
ce vaccin relativement mauvaise presse
en france il est considéré comme moins
un peu moins efficace ou carrément moins
efficace que les vaccins et rennes comme
le vaccin pfizer ou le vaccin moderna et
de plus moins bien tolérée
donc je voudrais très brièvement évoqué
quelques fêtes qui indique ce que ceci
n'est pas exact déjà j'ai indiqué des
pourcentages de protection de l'ordre de
80 % qui sont excellents lorsqu'ils ont
et deltell qui l'ont été dérivé des
études de phase iii des études initiales
et on il faut y ajouter à nouveau des
données qui sont comme en israël
intéressante lorsqu'elles sont obtenus
par vaccination entre guillemets envie
réelle quand on a commencé avec celle
des populations et nous disposons depuis
48 heures de données qui viennent des
cosses puisque la grande-bretagne
globalement commencer à vacciner avec le
produit astrazeneca dès début janvier
donc évidemment à nouveau ce sont des
données court terme mais de donner assez
encourageante puisque trois quatre
semaines ou quatre à cinq semaines après
l'administration de la première doses de
ce vaccin
environ quatre cent mille personnes en
écosse les données ont besoin d'encore
d'être précisées le travail ou net n'a
pas encore été acceptée pour publication
mais enfin il existe sous forme de prêts
prime donc on peut s'inspirer de ce qui
a été relaté de ce que l'on peut lire
donc le taux de protection analysé à
travers les hospitalisations donc est un
paramètre important évidemment
permettant d'évaluer l'efficacité d'un
vaccin du vaccin
astrazeneca est égal on va dire qu'il
mène légèrement supérieur mais il est
égal au taux de protection assurée par
le vaccin ryder qui a été administré
environ à 700 milles et que 700 milles
écossais either 400 milles et que ses
astra zeneca on est au même niveau de
protection très élevé au-dessus 90% en
excès plus comme dans l'étude clinique
donc ce qui est tout à fait remarquable
et qui indique en fait que ce vaccin est
un vaccin efficace un très bon vaccin et
l'information supplémentaire même s'il
faut être prudent dans l'interprétation
parce qu'il n'ya pas absolument toutes
les informations dans le l'article tel
qu'on peut le lire pour l'instant il
semble que ce vaccin soit efficace chez
les personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans je
rappelle que jusqu'au jour jusqu'à ce
jour excusez moi il n'y avait pas eu
d'études analysant l'efficacité de ce
vaccin au delà de l'âge de 65 ans d'où
le fait que la haute autorité de santé
en france a préconisé son emploi avant
l'âge de 65 ans donc pour la première
fois il y a des résultats
envie réelle entre guillemets et sur un
grand nombre de personnes de la
vaccination de personnes âgées plus de
65 ans jusqu'à 80 cents et au delà et
avec une efficacité qui est également
bonnes donc si ces résultats se
confirment on a là une excellente
nouvelle puisque là cela pourrait
suggérer que ce vaccin pourrait être
proposée préconisé pour les personnes
âgées de 65 à 74 ans qui dans l'immédiat
ministre l'a rappelé il ya un instant ne
dispose pas d'un vaccin alors qu'eux ils
sont à risque d'infection sévère donc je
sais que la haute autorité de santé a
été saisie par le ministère de la santé
pour évaluer cette situation mais il ne
peut être question de décision immédiate
puisqu'il faut pouvoir se fonder sur des
données très précises et complètement
validé mais c'est un signe très
encourageant
donc voilà pour l'efficacité donc il
n'ya pas lieu de considérer que ce
vaccin est un vaccin entre guillemets de
deuxième catégorie ou que sais-je qu'on
a pu entendre
il est tout à fait efficace il a sa
place complètement dans l'arsenal de la
vaccination
le second point pour terminer ce qui
concerne la tolérance de ce vaccin
il est exact que des personnes jeunes de
20 30 40 ans qui ont été vaccinés avec
l'astra zeneca rld ce sont de jeunes
professionnels de santé tels que cela a
été proposé il ya maintenant une dizaine
de jours donc certains d'entre eux ont
présenté dans les 48 heures qui suivent
la vaccination une espèce de syndrome
grippal de la fièvre des maux de tête
des motets des frissons donc une
situation désagréable bien sûr et pour
certains qui ont entraîné un arrêt de
travail
donc évidemment cela a créé un tout
petit peu d'émoi épouse chez certains
une réticence un retrait mais je ne veux
pas recevoir un vaccin qui qui va me
rendre malade même si c'est bref alors
d'abord c'est bref c'est pas grave
donc cela cesse sans aucune espèce de
séquelles donc ses premiers points et
surtout il faut considérer qu'en fait il
existe un moyen assez simple très simple
de prévenir pour l'essentiel cette
réaction excessive au vaccin ce qui
survient chez les sujets jeunes qui ont
un système immunitaire très puissant
c'est tout simplement de prendre du
paracétamol médicament que je touche
chacun connaît d'en prendre un comprimé
justement la vaccination et si
nécessaire de continuer à le prendre
pendant 48 heures toutes les six heures
comme c'est comme ce médicament est
appliqué lorsque nous avons un syndrome
grippal
les anglais ont montré que cette
approche était efficace et donc doit
provenir
l'essentiel de cette réaction excessive
donc finalement que l'on considère le
vaccin ce vaccin astrazeneca sous
l'angle de l'efficacité ou sous l'angle
de la tolérance
les données on adapte un tout petit peu
l'application de ce vaccin en y ajoutant
le paracétamol les données sont tout à
fait satisfaisantes
il est efficace il est sûre il peut être
administré donc il n'y a aucune raison
de retarder l'application de ce vaccin
aux personnes dont la solidarité de la
santé a parlé un instant les
professionnels de santé donc les jeunes
et moins jeunes mais aussi bien sûr et
eux n'ont d'ailleurs aucune réaction
particulière les personnes âgées entre
50 et 65 ans et qui ont des comorbidités
les deux millions et demi de personnes
qui doivent être vaccinés dans dans les
meilleurs délais donc je pense qu'il
faut que nous soyons tous rassurés mais
les professionnels de santé et les
personnes susceptibles d'être vacciné
parle astrazeneca ce vaccin peut être
utilisée sans aucune arrière pensée et
sans retard
il en va du développement selon le
rythme nécessaire du programme de
vaccination en france
voilà je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le professeur pour ces
informations à la fois précise et
encourageante
mes chers concitoyens les douze derniers
mois que nous avons traversées resteront
dans l'histoire comme une épreuve
exceptionnelle exceptionnel par sa
nouveauté exceptionnel par sa dimension
planétaire exceptionnelle par les
contraintes inédite qu'elle nous a fait
subir mais aussi par les ressources que
nous avons su mobiliser pour y faire
face les ressources scientifiques des
ressources médicales les ressources
financières mais aussi morale et
psychologique
cette épidémie nous a éprouvé nous
éprouve par sa durée et sa dureté par
ces évolutions souvent imprévisible mais
cette épidémie nous en verrons le bout
la progression de la campagne vaccinale
nous permet de nous fixer un cap
la fin du printemps à cet horizon la
protection des plus vulnérables
devraient nous permettre de réduire les
effets de site épidémie sur la
population toute entière
d'ici là nous devons tenir ensemble nous
devons poursuivre nos efforts
restez vigilants à titre individuel
rester solidaires sur le plan collectif
et
avoir adapté nos mesures à l'évolution
de la situation sans retard ni
précipitation dans la recherche des bons
équilibres dans le dialogue toujours
avec les élus et les territoires dans la
transparence et la vérité dans le
respect de notre seul objectif vous
protéger je vous remercie et je me tiens
à votre disposition avec le ministre le
professeur fisher pour répondre à vos
questions
vengeance le premier ministe bastia
angers pour tf1 lci
dans les vingt départements que vous
avez cités qui vous inquiète le plus
vous avez parlé de mesures similaires à
celles qui ont été annoncées à dunkerque
et à nice est ce que ça veut dire que ce
serait forcément des confinement le
week-end comme ce qui a été annoncé dans
ces départements là où est ce que il est
possible que ce soit pourquoi pas
d'autres mesures pourquoi pas par
exemple déconfinement en semaine ou
alors d'autres pistes que vous pourrez
peut-être évoqué est par ailleurs
al'inverse si j'ose dire puisque vous
pour l'instant privilégié la piste de
mesures territorialisée est ce que dans
les départements qui vous inquiète le
moins il est envisageable d'alléger
certaines mesures pourquoi pas d'ouvrir
les lieux culturels notamment les musées
merci bien
donc il ya deux questions n'est d'accord
je réponds tout de suite
la nature des mesures que nous pourrions
prendre je vais être très précis à
l'échéance du week end pas celui-là le
suivant après les concertations
si la situation dans ces départements
dans ces territoires venait encore à se
dégrader
nous envisageons évidemment que ce soit
des mesures de la nature de celles
prises en concertation à nice dans
l'agglomération niçoise au sens large et
à dunkerque et nous verrons là aussi en
fonction des réalités locales puisque
nous avons fait le choix merci de le
souligner de la territorialisation s'il
ya lieu au cas par cas de prendre des
mesures complémentaires
nous nous adapterons la réalité
l'objectif est de ralentir au maximum la
progression épidémique
malheureusement j'allais dire sur le
plan national vous avez raison il ya des
gelées dit c'est ce qui justifie cette
stratégie territoriale
il ya des départements des zones
urbaines où effectivement nous
constatons des situations mieux
maîtriser mieux maîtriser voire en
légère baisse par rapport
vous savez quand on raisonne en moyenne
sur 7 jours néanmoins l'évolution
générale globale en france et en europe
où vous voyez même les pays qui ont
confiné durement observer une reprise
des taux d'incidence ne nous permettent
pas à ce jour d'envisager des mesures de
relâchement toutefois vous avez raison
sur le principe une approche
territoriale en fonction de l'évolution
des données devrait pouvoir nous
permettre de prendre de telles mesures
ne tirait curtea france 2 est-ce que
puisque vous adapter le dispositif vous
pourriez aller jusqu'à par exemple
attribuer un nombre de vaccins
différents en fonction des zones les
plus touchées et en fonction des zones
des mois touché un peu plus dans les
zones touchées un peu moins en bretagne
au pays basque par exemple et puis on a
une actualité sportive ce week-end le
quinze de france ne pourra pas jouer
visiblement il ya eu un certain nombre
de choses qui se sont déroulés notamment
pendant les entraînements il a été
conseillé aux casses de france de ne pas
s'entraîner il semble qu'il se soit
entraîné pourrait-il y avoir des
sanctions de la part du gouvernement
aussi l'enquète étaient à charge contre
par exemple les entraîneurs ou
l'encadrement l'équipe de france alors
je vais demander à olivier vérins de
vous répondre sur les la location de
doses vaccinales en fonction des
réalités épidémique je vous fait
observer que j'ai déjà indiqué dans mon
propos que nous avions recouru à cette
technique si ce film est fait ainsi
notamment lorsque c'est le cas de la
moselle le variant sud africain était
plus important bon je vais laisser à
olivier ferrand le soin de compléter ma
réponse oui
oui nous avons effectivement opté pour
des stratégies territoriales là où
c'était absolument nécessaire du vaccin
arn messagers en moselle parce que là
bas il ya du variant sud africain qui
circulait en quantité et puis tu vas du
vaccin à nice et à dunkerque notamment
mais pas que en renfort en supplément
après faut savoir que nous avons fait le
choix de vacciner en flux tendu dans
notre pays c'est à dire que dès que des
doses arrivent elles partent dans les
territoires elles sont dans les 1200
centre chacun peut se rendre compte si
vous allez sur le site data.gov vous
verrez en open data la totalité des
stocks dont dispose chaque centre dans
notre pays aujourd'hui dans les six
semaines à venir
vous pouvez le comparer au nombre de
rendez-vous qui ont été pris par chaque
centre ont vérifié cas une bonne
corrélation entre les deux époux et
suivre centre par centre le nombre de
vaccinations qui ont été fait ce choix
de la transparence
il était aussi pour garantir à chacun
qu'il y avait un traitement je dirais
égalitaire sur tout le pays maintenant
évidemment quand vous êtes à dunkerque
que vous avez 1 % de la population qui
tombent malades ducobu chaque semaine et
que vous avez des personnes âgées qui ne
sont pas encore protégez vous dit on il
faut qu'on intervienne donc il faut
qu'on fasse de un peu de réorganisation
un peu de redistribution mais on ne peut
pas déshabiller paul pour habiller
jacques
vous imaginez bien que si nous disions
qu'on va enlever des vaccins dans tel
endroit pour finalement donner ailleurs
et qu'on devait annuler un certain
nombre de rendez vous ce serait voilà
donc on le fait avec parcimonie quand la
situation sanitaire le justifier
l'imposent
quant au quinze de france s'est posé
cette question évidemment c'est un sujet
difficile de pas pouvoir voir jouer le
quinze de france avant de parler
chanceux de sanctions faut-il savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé je pense
que les joueurs sont déjà eux même
sanctionné de pas pouvoir jouer je pense
qu'ils en sont très malheureux donc le
sujet vous la veillée suivie de près par
le ministère des sports en lien avec la
fédération française de rugby
ne préjugeons pas de en quoi que ce soit
des suites qui pourront être données à
tout ça il faut d'abord analyser et
connaître encore une fois je pense que
là la pénalisation la sanction est déjà
donné avec l'impossibilité
de jouer comme vous l'avez rappelé oui
bonjour j'ai un numéro pour la sp2
question la première mardi soir vous
étiez à l'hôpital d'argenteuil où
seulement 30% des personnels soignants
été vaccinées non parfois de doses mais
plutôt par les dix ans comment vous
expliquez que ceux qui sont au final les
vitrines les promoteurs de cette
campagne vaccinale soit aussi réticents
à se faire vacciner
et puis la deuxième concerne d
expérimentation qui pourrait être mené
comme certains élus vous le demande
pour ouvrir des restaurants sous couvert
bien évidemment d'un test négatif bien
je vais laisser le professeur fisher le
soin de répondre à votre première
question vous avez qu'à l'observer
puisque nous y étions ensemble dans cet
établissement que à chaque fois quand
même qu'on a interrogé les poubelles de
santé en tout cas ce que nous avons
croisés qui n'étaient pas vaccinés mais
auquel nous avons demandé s'il avait
l'intention de faire à chaque fois la
réponse a été positive
donc nous avons pleins d'espoir mais
c'est un c'est une vraie question si je
peux être monsieur fisher qui connaît
bien le sujet c'est le sujet que j'ai
évoqué brièvement tout à l'heure qui est
la survenue chez certains jeunes
soignants de ces syndromes pseudo
grippaux a créé une certaine réticence
je pense
le phénomène existe mais il a été un
tout petit peu amplifié et donc encore
une fois il existe une possibilité
technique simple d'y remédier il me
semble d'ailleurs qu'à travers de
nombreuses rencontres et discussions
mois que j'ai pu avoir au cours de ces
derniers jours avec un très grand nombre
de soignants par visioconférence en
toute la france j'ai l'impression que
petit à petit ce sentiment d'inquiétude
ou de doutes sur ce vaccin est en train
de s'estomper nous plutôt optimiste sur
le fait que les choses repartent mais il
faut expliquer réexpliqué rassuré parce
que ce sont des faits solides que ce
vaccin est à la fois efficace et bien
toléré si on la ministre avec du
paracétamol j'ai pas recommencer puis
j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais mais il
faut il faut faire des oeuvres de
pédagogie et nous professionnels de
santé devons le faire en tout premier
lieu je peux être sur les
expérimentations enfin je peux en dire
un mot puisque vous le savez
certainement déjà été
décidée ou envisagées notamment dans le
champ culturel ou dans le champ sportif
que nous évoquions tout à l'heure ce
sont des expérimentations qui sont
conduites évidemment sous le contrôle et
dans le cadre de protocoles fixé
conjointement avec les autorités
sanitaires
donc vous avez rappelé aussi que des
élus locaux je crois que c'est dans
votre question on en demande et nous
tenons à les associer mais s'agissant
d'une question éminemment sanitaires
nous souhaitons que l'état le conserve
la direction la conduite de ces
expérimentations c'est à dire la fois
leur méthodologie leur suivi ensuite les
décisions qui leur qu'il aura lieu d'en
tirer
s'agissant des restaurants que vous avez
évoqué évidemment le sujet est aussi sur
la table mais un peu plus délicat dans
la mesure où nous avons là pour le coup
une littérature scientifique je pense le
contrôle du ministre de la santé
démontrant évidemment que il s'agit
d'établissements recevant du public ou
le maximum de précaution doit être pris
puisque comme vous le savez on ne peut
pas porter le masque mais il faudra et
c'est tout l'enjeu des progrès de la
vaccination et et de de l'immunisation
en france envisager la réouverture
évidemment de ces établissements
également bon jour elisa verte lomé pour
bfm tv j'ai deux questions vous avez
parlé d'une surveillance renforcée dans
20 départements qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement et question
subsidiaire à dunkerque le variant
angles avaient progressé très vite de 50
à 90% autrement dit est-ce qu'il est
encore temps d'attendre dans les
départements que vous avez ciblé avant
de voir si ces mesures sont efficaces ou
pas et puis une question qui en
découlent à partir de quel seuil de
départements concernés peut-on
considérer que la territorialisation
n'est plus utile et qu'il faut passer à
des mesures nationales
autrement dit si l'île de france la
semaine prochaine ça ne s'améliore pas
est-ce qu'on peut prendre des mesures
supplémentaires dans la région capitale
sans que ça concerne tout le pays merci
beaucoup
le ministre va va vous répondre juste
rapport à la fin de votre question on
dirait on n'est pas tout à fait pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent bien dans la
situation de la fin du
d'octobre nous avions dû le perdre
république décider du confinement
nous avions une véritable flambée
épidémique à peu près nationale c'est à
dire une accélération beaucoup plus
forte des cas constaté que nous l'avons
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a un phénomène de montée
réelle que j'ai décrite au début de mon
intervention mais qui est plus lente
bon ce qui nous permet je crois de voir
des mesures fortes mais adapté
territorialisée parce que comme vous le
savez comme les cartes le montrer elle
n'est pas équivalente partout mais
évidemment si nous avions des flambées
épidémiques constater sans doute que la
logique territoriale comme nous l'avions
constaté récemment ne seraient plus
adaptées monsieur le ministre et
solidarité de la santé
le meilleur exemple c'est le nord où
j'étais fière dunkerque une incidence
donc c'est le reflet de la circulation
du virus 900 cas pour 100000 habitants
sur une semaine
lille qui fait partie du même
département 76 d'incidence 12 fois moins
est-ce qu'on va apporter les mêmes
solutions à lille et à dunkerque
la réponse à des noms donc là on est
même dans l'infra départementale ont
fait vraiment un travail à façon dans
les alpes-maritimes où j'étais samedi
c'est les deux et urbaine de nice et de
menton c'est 88% à population mais ça
veut dire qu'à une partie du département
qui n'est pas concernée par les mesures
de gestion et par le confinement le
week-end parce que c'est là qu'on
constate aussi que le virus circule
beaucoup donc cette territorialisation 1
je crois que les français y aspirent je
lis beaucoup ce qui est écrit j'écoute
beaucoup ce qui se dit les français
souhaitent que la territorialisation et
autant que nous pouvons le faire je
pense que nous devons le faire ça c'est
important
ensuite vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre on est on est pas
aujourd'hui dans une exponentielle à
dire qu'on n'a pas une croissance
fulgurante du nombre de cas qui fait qu'
on est obligé de prendre des mesures en
catastrophe on est sur une croissance
lente une croissance réelle et avec
encore des choses qu'on n'explique pas
complètement
il ya encore des endroits en france en
allemagne en suisse j'en discute
beaucoup avec mes homologues ministres
de la santé européens parlent quasiment
tous les jours les uns des autres où on
constate qu'il ya beaucoup de variantes
mais pas beaucoup de cas à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de corrélation systématique
entre la présence des variants et la
circulation du virus donc ça ça aussi ça
impose en double pas ça impose mais ça
nous autorise à avoir cette espèce
d'observation active
non pas de l'attentisme et une
observation active et puis je crois que
les français ont vraiment pris le
message d' alerte sanitaire que nous
lançons depuis quelques semaines et
c'est encore une fois dans le
comportement de chacun au quotidien
qu'on peut faire reculer le virus et
gagner du temps gagner du temps chaque
personnage est que nous vaccinons est
une personne âgée qui n'est pas à risque
d'aller en réanimation ou de décéder et
c'est un lit de réanimation qui peut
être utile pour d'autres patients qu'ils
aient le coquinou qui n'est pas le cas
au vide chaque jour que nous gagnons est
un jour qui nous rapproche deux périodes
climatiques dont on sait qu'elles sont
moins propice à la circulation du virus
chaque jour que nous gagnons ça nous
permet d'expérimenter des traitements
dont on pense qu'ils ont des chances de
toutes les chances de pouvoir être actif
et là aussi de limiter les risque de
formes graves et donc de protéger la
santé des habitants
et chaque jour que nous gagnons c'est un
jour de moins de fermeture des commerces
de de l'attestation de limitation des
nous tenons compte vraiment de toute la
situation
la santé mentale des français est une
donnée préoccupante à laquelle nous
tenons beaucoup
les aspirations légitimes de maintenir
un certain niveau de liberté même dans
un contexte épidémique difficile
évidemment que nous en tenons compte
nous faisons toutes les décisions ont
trébuché le confinement c'est une mesure
qui est prise lorsqu'il n'ya vraiment
plus d'autres options plus d'autre
alternative que nous savons que
l'hôpital est un risque de débordement
que rien n'arrêtera la course folle du
virus nous parlons là aujourd'hui d'une
croissance épidémique certes depuis cinq
jours importante qui a nous nous laisse
imaginer qu'elle pourrait se poursuivre
dans les prochains jours mais qui n'est
pas encore dans l'état la situation dans
lequel elle était au mois d'octobre ou
au mois de février et de mars de l'année
dernière et je me permets juste pour
compléter j'enjoins vraiment les
soignants assure vacciner parce que
c'est pour répondre aussi à la question
tout à l'heure ça me démangeait je suis
moi-même membres de la famille des
soignants doivent être vaccinés avec le
astrazeneca
je me sens je me sens non mais je me
sors depuis 2 je n'ai pas relâché les
gestes barrière je n'ai pas enlevé le
masque que je n'ai pas je vais toujours
autant attention qu'auparavant mais je
sais il parti de macky qui sait que j'ai
commencé à être vaccinés et que donc et
c'est plutôt sécurisant vu la mission
qui est la mienne aussi que le risque de
faire des formes graves il s'éloigne
jour après jour
les soignants ils sont responsables ils
savent le fonctionnement d'un vaccin ils
savent aussi ce que c'est que le coc vie
disons étaient ils n'ont vécu moi je les
enjoins à faire confiance à la politique
sanitaire de ce pays à se faire vacciner
savez ce n'est pas un problème franco
français c'est la même chose en
allemagne en suisse en italie en espagne
où il ya généralement un peu de latence
mais je suis convaincu que le professeur
fisher que les soignants danseurs
vacciner massivement les quelque dix
mille soignant par jour qui reçoit de la
strada n'est qu'à dix mille soignant par
jour ce n'est pas rien et dans les ehpad
on constate qu'il ya encore un certain
nombre d'établissements qui accueillent
des personnes âgées très fragile très
fragile où les soignants ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner
ça me pose je vous le dis un problème
comme ministre comme sain comme citoyen
il ya presque une question éthique
derrière donc vraiment il faut y aller
il faut se faire vacciner c'est
important une dernière question si vous
voulez bien jean yves godeau pour europe
1 on a compris la stratégie de
territoire par territoire en fait c'est
la stratégie que vous aviez annoncé
avant l'été avant de caler avec la
situation à marseille est ce que là vous
pensez vraiment avoir trouvé la solution
pour éviter le confinement nationale et
puis permettez moi juste de relayer une
question de michel rose de reuters
de plus en plus d'études confirme une
efficacité quasi similaire
des vaccins fraser et astrazeneca dès la
première dose seriez vous prêt à espacer
les doses pour accélérer le nombre de
personnes immunisées
ça c'est pour monsieur fisher qui va
s'avancer oui merci de la première
question parce que on a l'impression
qu'on découvrait maintenant les
stratégies territorialisée de lutte
contact vide on les a utilisés déjà vous
l'avez rappelé là aussi tout le monde je
crois collectivement progresser quand on
a je vous le rappelle commencer par des
stratégies territorialisée qui
concernait un certain nombre
d'établissements recevant du public
je pense avoir skié au bardo restaurant
cela commande et avait suscité un
certain de réactions vives
bon c'était pourtant en effet faire je
constate que collectivement
collectivement nous progressons puisque
sur ces stratégies territories et
qu'encore une fois nous avons déjà
utilisé on arrive à trouver plus
facilement des chemins parce que je
pense que nous avons tous ensemble
appris de cette épidémie est que ce
qu'on a pu prendre pour des mesures
arbitraires ou technocratique étaient en
fait des mesures nécessaires pour la
santé publique puis l'état est là pour
ça pour dire un moment donné il faut
agir bon ça renvoie à la question
précédente
il ya un moment où le degré de
circulation virale la flambée épidémique
ne nous permet plus de rester instable
territoriales parfois aussi
souvenez-vous parce que cette épidémie
que je commence à connaître
évidemment pas simple voilà alors où
vous faites tout depuis paris vous êtes
centralisateur où vous adopter des
stratégies territoriales et abc
compliqué on n'y comprend plus rien
c'est pas la même mesure qui va
s'appliquer dans tel territoire etc
bon évidemment rien n'est simple mais
encore une fois comme viens de
l'expliquer parfaitement le ministre
solidarité de la santé la situation actu
elle est aussi pour partie pas toujours
très bien explicable je pense que ces
variants ils introduisent encore on peut
le regretter évidemment mais c'est une
réalité des éléments de complexité dans
l'analyse et dans l'appréhension des
situations bon vous allez avoir à même à
données comparables des conséquences
comparables
c'est pas toujours le cas normalement se
dire oui si la le pourcentage de
variants dans la totalité des cas
constatés est le même le même pardon
dans deux départements on devrait avoir
des taux d'incidence l'évolution ce
qu'on appelle le r c'est à dire la
rapidité de progression de l'épidémie à
peu près identique alors que des écarts
c'est un peu c'est sûrement cette virée
des fois ce sont des écarts
considérables d'ailleurs vous le savez
parfaitement puisque toutes les données
sont en ligne donc nous agissons
toujours avec ce respect de l'équilibré
quand il faut agir agir parce qu'on ne
peut pas laisser d'épidémie flamber pour
l'instant vous avez raison nous sommes
dans une logique territoriale d'action
forte déterritorialisé et nous aviserons
parce que c'est notre devoir en fonction
de l'évolution de l'épidémie
monsieur professeurs pour la deuxième
question alors hein c'est un sujet de
débat qui n'est pas complètement clos
parce qu'on le retrouve dans la
littérature scientifique pratiquement
chaque semaine
mais enfin parce qu'il ya des arguments
dans les deux sens mais enfin il y a
aujourd'hui je pense un consensus mais
une opinion largement dominante de
penser qu'il ne faut pas et ce passé-là
doses des vaccins arn donc de rester à
ce qui est préconisé en france
aujourd'hui première dose et secondes
aux quatre semaines plus tard les
arguments sont d'une part le fait que le
lit ar d'informations sur ce qui se
passe si on retarde la seconde dose il
ya quand je dis guerre c'est qu'il y en
a quand même une toute première qui
arrive qui vient des données écossaise
qui montre que pour les personnes
puissent quand la grande bretagne a
choisi elle contrairement au reste de
l'europe a pris la décision pardon de
retarder leur l'administration de la
seconde dose donc pour les écossais est
vacciné par le vaccin
kaiser et rennes puisqu'il au bout de
quatre semaines j'ai indiqué qu'ils
avaient un très bon succès de la
vaccination mais à six semaines
il ya une perte de 20 points de
protection ce sont les premières données
qui suggèrent qu'il ne faut pas attendre
d'autre part dans les données
israélienne auquel j'ai fait allusion
tout à l'heure j'ai indiqué que
l'efficacité était absolument
remarquable lorsqu'on observe sept jours
après le second vaccin
mais si on regarde l'efficacité juste
avant l'injection du second vaccin il y
à un décalage de 20 à 30 points à
nouveau donc tous ceux ci sont des
éléments pas absolument définitif
évidemment mais qui vont dans le sens de
rester strictement dans le cas de ce qui
a été définie dans les protocoles de
classe écartés de ces protocoles de
palet dans l'inconnu se dotant et pour
monsieur le premier ministre vient de le
rappeler
nous sommes dans le contexte des
variants des variants à l'égard desquels
même si pour le variant britannique au
moins les vaccins que ce soit sera
zeneca ou pfizer fonctionne très très
bien sont quand même une menace sur
l'efficacité des vaccins peut pas se
permettre de prendre de risque et enfin
tout dernier point les personnes
actuellement vaccinés sont des personnes
âgées ou des personnes très malades dont
le système immunitaire n'est pas aussi
fort que celui de jeunes personnes chez
lesquelles les vaccins étaient
initialement testé donc il faut prendre
aussi les maximum de précautions pour
que ces personnes soient entièrement
protégé donc et des arguments de
raisonnement théorique et maintenant
d'observation de par les différents pays
qui ont adopté des stratégies
différentes qui tous contre tous ces
arguments concours sur le fait de
maintenir cet écart à quatre semaines et
pas au delà pour les vaccins à rennes
pour le phrasé n'est qu'à ces différents
le but tout à l'heure merci beaucoup
merci mesdames et messieurs